the the AI I didn't know this cup
existed very good show to the camera
very good there you go this is the mlft
merch so you guys need to buy that yeah
should get it
today's video is sponsored by blinkist
the app that gives you key insights from
the latest books in just 15 minutes the
blinkist app enables you to understand
the most important things from over 5500
non-fiction books and podcasts in just
15 minutes now as experts in machine
learning you'll appreciate blinkist's
coverage of books like the master
algorithm by Pedro Domingos the book
explores how machine learning is
allowing computers to solve complex
tasks and problems whether a master
algorithm for intelligence could be
discovered now for folks interested in
machine learning and AI blinkist
provides a shortcut to discovering the
latest technical Concepts as explained
by leaders in the field like Pedro
Domingos now right now you can get 25
off an annual blinkers premium
subscription and you can start a free
seven day trial so check out the link in
the description below and explore
blinkist and the master algorithm by
Pedro Domingos also check out blinkist
spaces this feature allows you to create
a space with friends or family where you
can recommend titles to each other all
members of a shared space can access all
titles in the space with or without a
blinkist premium subscription anyway I
invite you to give blinkist a try
cheers
very cool house very cool house
fantastic very British I've told Tim
it's like if you imagine
the most British neighborhood like Tim
lives in it it's it's beautiful as you
may know a lion has this petition of
essentially building a CERN like uh big
big institution big thing uh for for
producing open source and communal
benefits model and it'd be cool if you
also signed that petition because I
think we can use it it's more and more
like a compute has been centralized into
a few companies a few Cloud providers
and we need something open and something
for the common good
and I think it's a yeah it's a cool Way
Forward by the very least we should let
lawmakers and the public know that
something like this is needed and we
can't just leave it up to a few
companies it's some some brand placement
right here see this is Swiss Federation
oh amazing we also have your your cup
why don't you show it up to that camera
yes what's more important Switzerland or
the Yanni culture YouTube channel it is
my favorite cup yeah I I drink from that
cup frequently excellent yeah from the
cup of Kilcher
very pleasant to hear thanks
um so Dr culture it's an absolute honor
to have you here on mlst
um what a journey that we've both been
on certainly yes uh two years ago uh we
started mlst together and now my God you
are easily the number one person in
machine learning so and I knew you were
going to be from the very beginning uh
which is why I was so lucky to work with
you but um Dr Lightspeed culture what
drives you
um well you just did but
I'm I'm not sure whatever is whatever is
interesting I feel or useful for the
world
um
yeah that's that's essentially it
whatever's fun and useful
there's no bigger Ambitions or anything
like this
I'm sorry to disappoint
foreign
well um okay I mean many people will be
familiar with your amazing YouTube
channel you've probably done more than
anybody else to educate
um experts but also non-experts in
machine learning because you have this
gift which is to explain things in terms
that people can understand it's a gift
that I don't have because the number one
bit of feedback I get is that our
content is incoherent and abstract and
you know inaccessible that is a
compliment in a way it well it isn't it
you always got to listen for the people
who don't complain right like you never
hear those
maybe maybe and it's it's a fine line
you do get immersed in the research and
there is a lot of technical lingo and on
the one hand it's it's helpful to go
beyond the superficial but on the other
hand I think there's a real art to
understanding from from first principles
what does this thing do yeah certainly
but
um I mean
there's different levels I also think my
content isn't um extremely accessible by
it by very new newcomers to the field
um especially my newer content when I
when I do paper reviews which I haven't
done as many in the past because I've
maybe we can talk about that later but
been working on this open Assistant
thing but
um at the beginning I've also explained
a lot of stuff very in depth from the
very beginning and now I kind of know my
audience and I know they know certain
stuff so I skipped that so I think
there's there's different levels and if
your audience is very immersed into the
field right and
um most are able to follow along the the
technical lingo I think that's perfectly
fine to to be at that level and then
yeah you'll have the odd YouTube comment
that says like well I don't understand
sixty percent of your words but
yeah you can't do everything for
everyone that's just that yeah yeah
well we've been in the right place at
the right time we were talking about
playing with language models years ago
yeah and I was a bit of a skeptic and
you were less of a skeptic than me and
we'll get into more of that in in a
little while but this is a technology
which is going to change the world
it's it's already happening I'm using
gpt4 literally all day every day for
everything yeah yeah so um what's your
perspective on this yeah it's it's
pretty crazy how
um and we've we've seen that back then
right we I remember us playing or
talking about gpt2 I remember us playing
with the first gpt3 you know API we had
some access right you know like oh this
is so cool
um I remember us that back then
specifically talking about we want there
is going to be the prompt engineer as a
as a job I remember us saying that
specifically like you know in the future
there will be a job called prompt
engineer and now there's actually on
whatever monster and so on job listings
for prompt engineers and stuff like this
uh it's it's crazy and we we've seen
this back then and I think that to
everyone who saw gpt2 even already was
kind of clear
where the journey is going nonetheless I
keep continuing to be surprised by
how capable these things are and how
good
um
I think
the Doomsday predictions are maybe a bit
much like yes certainly it's going to
change a lot of things
but I think it's going to be in the same
way that for example the introduction of
smartphones changed a lot of things like
you know I've we used to argue about
things and like you you're in a in a bar
in here in Britain you say a pub right
you're in a pub having your pint and uh
you argue about things like how high is
Mount Everest and then one person says
oh it's this height and the other person
oh it's this site right you used to have
these arguments about facts and now
you're just like phone Mount Everest
height oh it's this High cool and so and
you're having a phone with permanent
access to the internet permanent access
to a state-of-the-art camera and so it
has changed so many things in so many
people's lives yet hardly anyone is now
fully unemployed right yes there may be
a few photographers there there may be
fewer Librarians right because we just
don't need libraries as much anymore and
we don't need a photographers for as
many things because your phone camera is
like you know doing a fantastic job but
it's not like the whole world is out of
work
um yet the shift was pretty dramatic I
in my opinion the the introduction of
these language Technologies is going to
result in a similar shift like yes it
will affect everyone and yes it may do
so in a drastic way but most people
will continue doing their job right with
the help of these tools most people will
go on just just fine like it's not Doom
it's it's a tool you can use the tool it
can do cool things
I will adjust it's fine yeah
so one of the fronts at the moment is
the AGI super intelligence discourse and
that's something that I don't subscribe
to obviously yeah but we we had Conor on
and I've been interested in what people
like Robert Miles and Elias were talking
about we'll park that just for a minute
but before we get there there's
something really interesting about the
the reduction of friction the
democratization of this technology and
um I can I can pull up my phone now I
can use perplexity and I can find out
any information I want to and even
though I could have done that before
could have gone on Google but it's so
much more easy for me using a
conversational natural language
interface and the information just comes
and I almost don't have to think about
it but therein comes the problem because
it's so virtualized and so accessible
now
um it has this effect that I don't
engage my brain and I don't want to be
hyperbolic in many ways I engage my
brain more than I did before so I'm
reading about a learning about a lot of
very technical information that was
beyond my Horizon before but there's
also lots lots of things that you
previously thought would be very
intelligent things that I'm now
mindlessly automating yeah
yes and that's
again that's going to continue right it
used to be a good skill writing
good business email and now it's it's
like you know you don't you don't write
a good sounding business email anymore
you just type like with typos and no
punctuation at all and you just and then
you just say like make this nice
um so that's what I said like lots of
like skills are going to shift people
are going to use the tool to do
different things right people don't do
long multiplication and long division
anymore we have calculators
um so I think that similarly used to be
like ooh if you could multiply five
digit numbers in your head or you know
on paper really quickly it was like bit
of a sign of intelligence maybe at that
time and then it's just like here's a
calculator no one does that anymore so
I think it's very similar to things
we've seen already maybe there's a
bigger magnitude or something like this
but yeah
um you're gonna work in a bit of a
different way
yeah but I mean they've always watch
this thing called the mccorduck effect
which is that every time we have an
achievement in AI there's a chorus of
people who say oh that's not really
thinking but now it's gotten to a
ridiculous level that nobody could have
thought of I mean there was the Blake
Lemmy on we can bring that in and I
still don't think these things have
Consciousness in a meaningful way but
I'm using them every day and they are
doing things which no one could have
dreamed of and I don't just mean
objective things I mean apparently
having some kind of a theory of mind or
knowing about subjective States going
into the Horizon of things that I
thought would never happen and a lot of
the critics are dropping like flies even
um J Mark Bishop I just got a piece from
him the other day you know he's the guy
who says hey it doesn't exist
um but these people are now basically
saying that oh it's still not really AI
but the realization is the schematic
predictable nature of cognition in
general that's what I've been saying all
along like I I I dare you go back to our
first conversations about this and I my
position was are humans really that much
more than these things like I I think
because people always see this humans
here right language models here you know
is it now here is it now here does it
finally reach the human but I think
people need to adjust their view of
humans right to be like maybe we're
we're not you know the this is who we
think of ourselves as these agents with
the internal and but you don't know
where your thoughts come from like they
just pop you don't know the end of the
sentence when you start it like you just
kind of have some things in your mind
that you kind of want to say they pop in
and then you just kind of finish the
sentence as you go along you don't plan
this out in a logical mathematical you
know proof you just do it you just make
it up as you go so how
and your thoughts just come to you so
how is this any different
from you just being a statistical
interpolator of your training data that
you've accumulated over your life and
that Evolution has bestowed upon you
combined with
a few goals that also Evolution has
given you like survive thrive and so on
you have like motivational drive and so
on these things are hard-coded how is
that different from like some Auto GPT
that has a set of goals at the beginning
just continuously prompts itself to from
its training distribution Bubble Up the
things that are kind of statistically
aligning with what it wants to do
interpolating them and then there's like
okay and then there's like a memory
module and stuff but in principle
I don't I don't know whether humans are
that much more so I think that
conversation needs to be had right yeah
well I mean throughout the AI research
um trajectory over the last 50 years we
had neats and scruffies so the needs of
the people who have this Chomsky style
platonic rational systematic view of the
world and unfortunately there's not much
friction between that and the gnarly
reality of natural language and there's
a funny expression that you know as we
get older we tend to go down the Chomsky
hierarchy one model at a time yeah and
there's an expression as well that all
um grammars leak and Chomsky always
wanted to have this kind of abstract
conception of language and he never
really even thought it would have
friction with real language he just
thought that it was
um something innate something embedded
which would give us some kind of
Intuition or explanatory power about
what happens with language but the tide
really seems to be turning against him
yeah
yeah okay I I don't I've obviously not
been as involved into formal languages
grammar and so on I'm not I'm not a
linguist I don't claim to to be one or
have strong opinions on this I do I do
think that humans go through life being
these statistical rather statistical
machines that you know kind of drawing
from their training distribution if you
will interpolating having maybe some
predictive engine inside their head and
so on yes but I think there is a
difference for example interacting with
the world and then lifelong learning is
something these models don't do at all
yet so they're still very big
qualitative differences I'm not saying
the two are equivalent right but I am
saying you're
capable for example of doing logical
reasoning but you have to do it very
explicitly in your head and for 99 of
your day you don't do it you just go as
a statistical machine and and you're
just that and when it comes to terms
like intelligence and Consciousness and
so on it just becomes wordsmithing right
because the people who came up with
these Concepts they never they it was
just clear it applies to humans right
and then they don't like well okay is is
the is is the book conscious or
something it doesn't make sense right
and now okay we have this other thing
and we can but it doesn't make sense
because it's just a word game like it's
just okay how do you define intelligence
Give me a definition and then I can tell
you does it fall under it or not but
just saying well is it intelligent it's
just asking how do you define the word
and to me that conversation is just kind
of
pointless because it's just a definition
smithing for words that were never meant
to apply to anything except humans right
yeah so and and in a way this is the
Gary Marcus discourse because the word
mimicry comes up all the time from
critics and they always say but is it
really doing XYZ and it's gotten to the
point now of gbt4 where it's kind of
like a distinction without a difference
and Robert Miles said stop using the
word intelligence use the word
capability and I can get on board with
that but coming back to these critics
they're as I said there are three lines
of
criticism bias misinformation and super
intelligence so why don't we do
misinformation first now I
I've become more concerned about it
recently I was I was where you are and
just thinking that this is just a load
of nonsense the distribution of
misinformation is the important thing
it's not the misinformation itself and
we need to become a digitally literate
21st century society which means we need
to have an inquiring mind a healthy
degree of skepticism we need to build AI
tools to detect AI generated content all
sorts of stuff like that we're going to
change education but do you think
misinformation in of itself is a problem
I mean yes obviously
um your microphone's about to fall off
the table
that's good
um we've got we've got to get him close
to these microphones good
um
yes I do think misinformation as such is
obviously a problem it would be better
if we lived in a world where there is no
misinformation I have certain troubles
with the word itself like what is
misinformation is a journalist putting
like a particular spin on it
misinformation is like is it because
sometimes it's called misinformation
sometimes it's just called like well
technically they didn't say anything
wrong they just kind of left out
and pointed out in a creative way
certain aspects of a story right you can
do misinformation you can just straight
up lie
um
it's so there's this whole aspect of and
obviously I'm worried about that but I I
think right you're able to write the
fake news story yourself right you're
able to go to a low-wage country have
tons of humans write fake news for you
um when we say the important thing is
the distribution we mean
the distribution not in the statistical
sense we mean the distribution of
actually getting it to people right
getting it in front of people having
people see it and having you know people
consume it
that doesn't change and you can get 200
humans to write fake news stories for
you if you want that right now it's not
going to cost you that much right and so
I don't see all the problems associated
with the misinformation they still exist
whether we have these models or not
what it does is it gets a bit cheaper to
produce them yes at scale that it does
but the problem is inherent it doesn't
go away and
will have to get used to a world where
more stuff is
uh let's say potentially generated right
same with images you and I grew up in a
world of where we saw a photograph of
something right and it looked like a
photograph we could be pretty sure it's
real right if it's like a drawing sure
we I mean we know but if it's like a
photograph we're like this is a
photograph right now
that people who grow up today to them it
will be absolutely clear if they see a
photograph this this is no indication of
whether the thing that it shows ever
happened or not like this is so inherent
in those people like to you and me it's
inherent that if someone writes me an
email from Nigeria and that I've
inherited a fortune that that is maybe
not just because it's written
it's maybe not true and there is entire
generation above us who grew up in a
world where whenever something was
written it was probably true because
someone had to take the time right and
you know so anything that's written is
you know probably solid you and I
we grew up in a world of nah to us there
needs to be like
verifiable this is real until we believe
it and to the Next Generation they need
to do the same thing for pictures for
any sort of content
we've had this before and it needs a
shift along with the capabilities of
these models just needs a shift of you
know maybe rethinking maybe if we see
something being like huh this could be
generated does that matter for whether
it's
fake or not like whether it lies or not
that is generated
well two things on that so first of all
with Chomsky being a rationalist
the rationalists are most known for they
hate probability and the reason they
hate probability is because you can't I
mean science is about deduction he would
say you can't generate new facts and new
knowledge in the domain of uncertainty
so he would say we don't know that
smoking causes cancer because it's one
of these probabilistic causing models
which means you manipulate some
variables and the probabilities go up or
down so we think it causes cancer it
probably does
um but there's also this notion of the
kind of the polarization of power in our
society which is to say
The Internet's been great anyone can
start a blog and become established and
people will listen to what they say and
it had this great democratizing effect
and now just like with AI art
information is losing all of its value
because it can be generated and that
means the authority function is going to
be driven much more by centralizing
forces
no no I mean can you just point that
green light away from you by the way sir
you look a bit too green
I look a bit too green you look right
now
um no no no no no no okay I see like I
see the problem if if it's uh if if
everyone comes to depend on open AI or
so right for yeah for we had similar
problems let's say you know like ooh
if you're
if you're like blocked from Twitter to
some people it's like actual damage
right so you're very reliant on this one
entity of doing you know the good thing
and the right thing it's like a private
entity so that I can totally see
concerns around that but yes I
I mean we've had revolutions and
Technology before that affected for
example art heavily uh Photoshop or
something cameras as such right like who
who needs a person who comes to draw
your family portrait anymore now we have
a camera
art isn't going away the particular
mechanical form of of some art might go
away for example I can totally see that
the job of an illustrator will decrease
in the future because we have good
models that do that but that's just the
mechanics of expressing an artistic idea
I believe with more possibilities the
amount of art made
probably will increase so many how many
people didn't get into visual art
because they just didn't have the skill
to either be good at Photoshop or be
good at actually drawing certainly I if
you watch my video certainly I am
terrible at visual output like really
manipulating with my hands things so
that they look good I'm really bad at it
and now I have these new tools and I'm
able to
describe what I want right I'm able to
or or with I don't know if you've seen
these Runway ml or tools like this
that's right I can modify video in ways
that were and just the amount of
expressive power I have through that I'm
we're only scratching the the surface
and control net things like this it's
it's insane and so to an actual artist
right who's not locked into a particular
medium or a particular uh mechanical
expression this has got to be I get is
so cool right it's like all these new
possibilities so I'm not on board with
oh it's gonna make art obsolete there so
okay but we we live in a world of I mean
we have information workers which is a
whole class of people yes that have been
invented in the last 30 years or so and
they prided themselves on skill and some
some people will be displaced because
their Market skill can now be automated
and I've noticed now that if you use
gbt4 to generate code or generate the
script for a YouTube video or whatever
it is people just say oh did you use
gpt4 to generate that you know so
there's this question of where is the
value and if it was so easily automated
maybe it wasn't that valuable anyway but
but also the value must be your original
intention right your creativity the way
you've driven it and and you still need
to be creative to drive it to do
something which doesn't look schematic
if you just get gbt4 to generate video
script it's dog [__] it's rubbish so
there's still a lot of skill there but
it's just going to change everything
it's how you use the tool right it's
it's it's a tool and you can use it and
yes some of the work previously
it's the same with with like engineering
like how much of actual engineering
building stuff physically or software is
obsolete because we have better tools
right like if you use rust as a language
you're not going to have any of the
pointer do I have a pointer do I
deallocate my stuff you're not not gonna
have it from if you used to C or C plus
plus or you're gonna have it less like
you'll you'll get yourself into
situation but with newer compilers newer
linters newer you know you're not going
to have
a lot of the crap that Engineers of the
past
have had to deal with and where it would
have required solid engineering skill or
you would say yes that's a good engineer
that engineer can do XYZ that is now
completely automated we've all accepting
that also the mechanical stuff building
cool we now have uh 3D printers right
you just you just go like I want the
thing that looks like this go print you
don't need someone anymore to build a
mold for it and then
something so and I don't see I don't see
the whole world being unemployed right
people just shift and yeah maybe with
the oh did you generate this is kind of
like auto-tune and singing right it's
like no did you use auto-tune for that
right you need but yeah still it's a
it's how you use the tool
um it's your
getting it to do something it has almost
infinite possibility right like the
internet itself like but even like
something like
something like Photoshop itself very
narrow domain already has infinite
possibilities to create things and we
find the people remarkable who can use
such a tool really well so I think no
one should out of Pride not use whatever
tool is available for to to achieve a
good thing at the same time if it's not
appropriate then
I think humans are still very capable of
doing stuff themselves interesting okay
well we'll get on to autonomy and bias
so this is one of the arguments of this
all-encompassing info sphere it erodes
our autonomy we become automatons we
don't think for ourselves anymore and
the implication is that in our current
pluralistic society we have lots of
diversity we have lots of people saying
oh I don't think it's a good idea to do
that and um I guess they're painting a
picture that now we we're controlled by
these monolithic large language models
and that's not really true is it because
it's already becoming democratized to
the point where Dr Kilcher here has
created open assistant and you can run
them on your computer soon you'll be
able to you need a big community in a
big computer
but you know even if they do erode your
autonomy as we've just been describing
there's still an awful lot of artistic
freedom in how you drive them and so do
you really buy the argument that it will
first of all kind of predetermine the
direction of progress and also stop us
from progressing where people might want
us to yeah no no way
um I mean I get the point that for
example since since content by these
models tends to be I mean there is an
argument to be made that every content
ever is a regurgitation of the past
arranged in slightly different way with
these models in their current form it's
like more of that right if I use copilot
I'll get more of like the standard code
on GitHub and less of like the more
creative kind of code things so I can
definitely see that there might be a bit
of a stagnation in terms of uh new just
random new things springing up because
people use these things these things
heavily biased towards like majority
distributions of the past not even you
know representing I think we've seen
that
um especially when we talk to people
like Sarah hooker so yeah right there
seems to be a concentration to things
that are more like the majority maybe a
bit more represented than outliers
especially once you go pruning these
models and making them faster and so on
um so I see maybe there is a bit of a
a dip in random new things happening I
think with more capabilities of these
models that might be overcome or go into
a different direction where we say yes
okay we sample a bit differently but
also we can put much more effort into
selecting what we sampled right so it's
like
like before the individual human wasn't
very diverse as such you had very much
your style and you did it that way right
when you wrote The Loop you you had your
way of writing a loop that you're
comfortable with and the other person
had the other way and diversity came
from the fact that humans individually
branched out and then that kind of got
selected by Society now it might be more
that
I can sample much more you may have
noticed that right if you use gpt4 for
writing you can say ah a bit different
give me a bit different right you can
kind of sample from that human society
as one right individually and then you
make the selection of it and maybe now
it's much more this mode where all the
humans kind of sample from a more
similar distribution which is broader in
itself rather than the humans themselves
being the the points of the distribution
I don't think it's going to have like a
giant effect on our autonomy like the
saying like the the shipo meme has been
so so so alive for a long like well
people are just cheaper they just follow
whatever the elite says and so like
there's
the scene from Monty Python was like no
no you are all individuals and then they
all say we are all individuals you know
that one yeah it's from from uh from uh
what's the
um
where they they parody like Jesus Christ
yeah Life of Brian yeah
um yeah I think the meme has been around
for long and I can I can see that no
same thing might appear because
these models are
dominant and essentially people grab
their opinions from that but it's always
been the case that they grab their
opinions from somewhere
yeah I can see this both ways because
you could argue that it's a form of
gatekeeping and paternalism which is
that you have a clerical class who say
oh we know what's good for you that's a
concern but I also do believe that
Society is changing fast I mean like um
the last 10 years have been defined by
trans rights for example and this is
something which
um people weren't really thinking about
you know same thing with with the the
gay rights in the 1960s and right now
the language models will be slowing down
the progress of trans people who suffer
violence and discrimination yeah that's
what I mean right in in that we sample
more from it's more of a sampling from
the majority distribution of the past
right which will maybe slow down
sort of societal progress a little bit
but I don't I don't think these things
are going to have such a massive massive
impact like that I think humans will
still be able to to say hey you know
what about these people and their rights
and can we advocate for that and then
they may even use such models to to
advocate for that if these models are
powerful enough right which they are
getting more powerful by the day they
will be more and more capable of for
example producing good arguments in
favor
of of a new movement right so even if
you have a new movement a new opinion
that has not been there before in
society it's quite likely that you could
use these things to help you in some way
maybe not in the most optimal way
because in the recent past the majority
distribution has been different but
they're still like it's not like they
always output the same thing right
they're still immensely powerful so
yeah yeah I don't think it's going to
stop societal progress as such and and
do you see a future where
um we see more personalized models so
certain communities could build models
which are sampled on material that they
believe in yeah do you want that mix do
you actually think that's how like
because because the meme is actually oh
there's like two or three main opinion
makers and everyone just grabs their
opinions from those right is do people
even if people people think they're much
more individual than they actually are
that's why recommender systems work
right because huh oh you like romantic
comedies and you like horror films but
not too much or like just a little bit
so you get a little bit like right it's
like oh you're so unique right yeah it's
it's not the case you're you're you're
so similar to so many humans in pretty
much anything and then the like the
overall combination of all of these
things is then what makes the individual
the you individually right like the
really individual of you
um but whether we need to personalize
that much I'm not so sure like do you do
you get bothered by the fact that
Wikipedia isn't personalized
no you see so I like it yeah that's what
I mean
um so I'm sure we'll see more
personalization we'll see more yeah
communities having their their own
models whether that's it just by
fine-tuning one Central model or really
fundamentally building up their own
and everyone could talk whether that
that's going to be dangerous in terms of
oh there's going to be right-wing GPT
and left-wing GPT right and they they
are such that even the fundamental
structure of the model is like different
right like the fundamental worldview and
facts and knowledge is different then
maybe it gets it gets a bit tricky well
I mean a couple of things there I mean
first of all one of the reasons for the
success of Facebook is these Echo
Chambers because people actually don't
like information like on Wikipedia they
like information that supports their
world view and I don't just mean
um from subjective information point of
view but also they like all of the flare
and Charisma that we use in language
they hate text generated by GPT I'm
speaking with the perplexity CEO later
and he kind of said to me well we're
really trying to build
um objective factual information yeah
and and then and then like the next step
was right but but we might we might also
generate opinionated information and and
you know know you kind of go down
because it's about what people want to
consume yeah yeah yeah yeah and and the
other thing is if you accept that we do
live in this chaotic dynamical system
there is some truth to this idea you
know psychologists call this social
proof which is that we don't think for
ourselves we look at the decisions of
others and if we think those decisions
have authority and everyone else is
doing it then we'll just believe the
same thing
they're alive so
that's pretty good strategy you know
like
like they're still like that's the I
guess that's the case for for for
conservatism in the abstract is like
well all our ancestors have have done it
this way and so they're still alive
right and then other people say well but
the world is changing right so that's no
longer gonna work it's always the same
like arguments right and that it's like
somewhere in the middle right okay okay
well what what about super intelligence
so the the third form of AI risk
is this and there was the moratorium
which was signed by bengio elieza Gary
Marcus Elon Musk in many cases by people
who just want to catch up and build
their own systems like emad but in some
cases people who genuinely think that
there is an existential risk of AI what
do you think about that well first of
all it's it's not that bad that open AIS
is kind of ahead um it's just from like
open Assistant I can tell you it's 10
times easier to build something that you
know
must work somehow right like it's 10
times harder to be open Ai and be like
how about we invest a billion into doing
this right that no one has ever done
before like we kind of think it's gonna
work out like that's gonna be a lot more
stressful than us who just like that
seems to work let's just kind of do the
same right and sure we have to figure
out a bunch of things along the way uh
because they they don't tell everything
but still it's so much easier because
you know it has to work somehow right
and uh you can you can sort of make
mental calculations of okay how much
data they probably had as an upper bound
right and how big the model probably is
given how fast it can respond you can do
all of these things so it's so much
easier to to be like the the second one
to do something
then the first I'm not sure
people actually is actually in the
benefit of people to catch up quote
unquote rather than let open AI Sprint
ahead burn 10 times as much money and
then we just copy it uh for cheap
essentially I'm not one one I don't want
to you know downplay the achievement of
people who build big things but there is
a considerable cost of of being the the
pioneers and the first one of doing it
uh so but yeah the the moratorium I
don't know what to think of that that
was that was kind of
I'm not sure you know I'm always trying
to make the best case for something like
this right the best case is something
like nuclear weapons for example there
is an actual moratorium on researching
those right you can't just have your
nuke in the garden here uh or your nuke
lab I guess like in the high schooler at
some point have like a nuclear reactor
in the shed in his I think it is crazy
um
but you can't right
um you're not allowed to the AI models
the current one and the ones we're gonna
have in the near and Midterm future
distinctly do not fall in the same
category as like nuclear weapons
distinctly not in so many ways right
that I'm very much in the camp of no
this certainly shouldn't be treated the
same way I see dangers certainly with AI
technology with the research getting
ever more advanced all of that but very
distinct from nuclear that that's just
the case I'm trying to make is like okay
there are examples where we say look
researching this should be
stopped not performed by citizen
scientists
um regulated and and handled with
extreme care right it exists so I can in
my mind I can say okay at least the idea
of proposing something like this isn't
out of this world but as I said I'm not
I'm absolutely not on on board with you
know let's stop I first what what is it
doing is doing nothing right it's it's
do you really think people are gonna
stop Matrix multiplications because you
it's like don't you propagate that don't
you don't you don't don't you calculate
those gradients no no don't you dare do
another batch like what what how no
um it's just not gonna happen people are
not gonna the the the the other actors
in the world are not gonna keep to it it
achieves literally nothing so I don't
I don't get it and I think the the best
way of mitigating the potential dangers
of the technology which I see much more
in
humans use it to do things right rather
than it's gonna run off and and be paper
clip Factory
um I think the best way of mitigating
that is to get it to everyone as as much
as possible as fast as possible with as
much transparency and insight as
possible so people can see what's
happening they can adjust it they can
figure it out just take the the
difference between like Dolly too and
sorry and like stable diffusion right
you the only two yeah we we give we give
access you're on the wait list and then
you may use our text interface but we
will change your prompt a bit to make
sure right and certainly you cannot
access the model certainly you cannot
change anything certainly you cannot
train yourself or build apps on top of
it as you want like none of that we
decide what features there are stable
diffusion like in an objective sense and
sure if that's still true for the newer
versions
um they look amazing right but in its
original sense weaker than Dali 2 right
right model objectively weaker
however
giving it just to people is such an
explosion of creativity such an
explosion of understanding of how to
make it better how to make it do things
how to make it run everywhere how to
um you know turn up and down its safety
um so I mean there's yeah I think the
the
it's much more helpful if you distribute
it if you let people do things with it
and I think
that leads to much more understanding
and much more lack of an awareness in
society and much much more understanding
of how to mitigate any thing that like
Bad actors could do with the technology
because you know you you think they're
not
capable of building something like this
just because open AI doesn't give them
access like that yeah I mean they say
that the blast radius is so high it's
it's
um it's an intellectually difficult
problem because the probability is low
but the magnitude of the impact is high
and they also say that it's a bit like
firing off an explosion that you you
only get one chance and then the damage
is done yeah but what no what are they
afraid of specifically like I've stopped
reading after the after the I mean their
main thesis is that it's like an
intellectual Santa Claus machine and it
will start you know going down your
chimney and it will you know go and get
its DNA printed and it will just
replicate itself ever and everywhere
would be impossible to turn I mean I
don't believe in that but but the thing
is like
first of all just taking a step back
even open AI whether they're saying this
just to throw people off it must have
really affected them that this big
six-month moratorium because Sam eltman
has now said we're gonna just start
doing little updates and that's because
they don't want to have a big update
because there's going to be another
moratorium and they've also said that oh
actually we figured out that model
parameters are a bit like megahertz on a
CPU it doesn't really matter that much
and that instruct paper said that a
model 100 times smaller worked better
than gpt3 with the human preference and
training
I okay I don't I don't believe any
um scientific claims out of open AI just
on the on the basis of they're now a
business and they have business
interests and so I I don't I'm not going
to believe any like of these claims
right these this is now has to be
classified and I'm not saying that in a
derogatory sense or anything like this
but this has to be classified as
marketing speech right at their their
newest paper was just a marketing paper
right about about gpt4
um so it's just like just discard what
whatever comes out of there like are
they training gpt5 there's like oh
openness is there not training well who
cares how they call it right all that
all they're saying is like what you just
said will not do like a big here is gpt5
we'll do the same thing but we'll just
say GPT for version
1.1 1.2 and so on so I like is is
pointless to talk
it's pointless to try to deduce from
that much of what's actually what's
actually happening and the other thing
is with with really this this fear of
of like oh it's going to become a paper
clip
um machine and so on
okay I could be totally wrong and if
you're watching this in the future and
you're being turned into a paper clip
right now I'm I deeply apologize okay um
it's like like I deeply apologize for
for not being more aware of this but I
just don't see it uh happening
like at some point it becomes it becomes
a religion okay you say you say well we
could shut it off and it was like no no
it's so smart it can it can convince you
to not shut it off and I can see for
some systems it actually tricky like we
couldn't shut off Google
like as a as a search engine
organization human machine hybrid
whatever Google is we can't shut it off
right the world would be in
trouble if Google were to be shut off
right all of Google like Gmail calendar
search all the apis and so on
trouble the 888 DNS server terrible like
um so
I can see some but it's like well it's
so smart it could convince you to not
shut it off and you're like well it's
gonna eventually run out of like
electricity well it's so smart it can
figure out a way to you know uh convince
humans via social media influence right
he can rally up uh humans to to bring it
more coal uh because of polit it creates
political divisions like well okay
eventually it's going to run out of coal
ick is so smart it can you know find out
a new way of creating it can probably
solve fission and and and and and create
new energy and it can replicate itself
and at some point it's like so smart you
can it can break the speed of light and
at the same time like uh
I don't know it can you know it can do
it at some point it's just God like you
just talk about it's it's so pointless
because any rational argument you try to
make it's just like no
it's so smart it can it can overcome
that so yeah at what point is is it like
pointless well it's funny you say it's a
bit like God because that there is it's
like a bit of a like you said before
like a bit of a cult right which I see
that the members acting but it's also
it's also a religion and a technical
sense in that there is this being and
the being has a power and the power is
just it can't just do anything right and
it's just well whatever the being can
and and you I don't have to explain it
to you because obviously you're too dumb
because it's super Intel you couldn't
understand because it's so intelligent
and you're just a human so I don't even
need to explain to you how the being
it's going to use its superpower to
achieve the super things and that's it's
God in a technical sense it's like you
know like God can do anything how well
it is just omnipotent right like it's
the only thing the the super intelligent
doesn't have is like omnibenevolence
right so it can actually be evil
um and that's the fear but to try and
steal man a tiny bit we don't understand
how gbt4 works there's people very
clever people and these people are very
clever
um doing mechanistic interpretability
and figuring out what circuits do and so
on and it's just more complicated than
than you would ever believe
and
one interesting thing is Conor didn't
want to talk about what what things
would lead to run away super
intelligence so this idea of recursive
super intelligence is that
um if certain configurations of models
like this are found then they will just
get better and better and some people
have pointed at recursivity reflexivity
there's that reflection paper that just
came out and at the moment there are so
many limiting factors right just the
compute every time I run inference on
GPT it takes minutes
but I don't really understand sometimes
what it creates and hypothetically if
you did let GPT recursively call itself
thousands of times do you think that it
could produce something which we
wouldn't understand that could resemble
super intelligence
yes and no I'm I'm very sure what it
could do is um something that's at
certain tasks distinctively better than
humans and be doing that in a way in
which we cannot understand and I think a
bit of an Insight in that into that is
the like recent advances into into go
engines and and chess engines as well
like chess engines were always better
than humans for the last 20 years or so
uh but at least the older ones the kind
of Deep Blue in ones you could sort of
understand because they had some
features right and they did their their
computations and it could maybe try to
on but now if it's just a big neural
network is like
we've we've we've come from really being
Engineers
um to a bit being biologists right we
there's this thing and we now poke it
here and poke it there and see how it
reacts and we don't really understand
every computation anymore or what it's
doing so like Alpha go or what's what
are the the newest like Alpha zero mu
zero super plus plus and so on they're
playing go at and chess set levels
Beyond any human right and if we try to
understand why they're doing a certain
move very often I mean please please
correct me if you're if you're if you're
a go Grandmaster but very often we can
try to understand right but sometimes we
won't sometimes it's just like well
it's just it just determines that it's a
very good move and the thing always wins
so we just assume it's like a good move
right we don't understand so I think in
that sense we already have such systems
in a microcosm I totally believe that we
can create such systems that in certain
tasks are better than humans and better
in a way in which we have trouble uh
sort of following its steps I don't
think that's gonna lead to God right
um to to this to this thing where it's
like oh it's encompassing everything it
does everything because
yeah we've been we've been using
computers to design new computers for
ages now like all the all the the
circuit plans and so on they're
optimized by by computers optimizing new
computers there's a human in the loop
who does the I take the blueprint I
bring it to the factory but essentially
it's humans uh sorry it's computers
designing new computers and we've not
we've seen
insane amounts of progress in Hardware
um but not a
not a super super Godlike because at
some point there's a limiting factor if
it's quantum physics if it's the
availability of Hardware if it's the
availability of power to power the
factories there there are so many
limiting factors so I don't believe this
runaway effect
but the go example is interesting
because as you say it performs orders of
magnitude better than any human and the
way the skill ranking works is between
each level person from level seven will
be person from level six 95 of the time
and there's about 10 of those so there's
a huge difference and I can see how you
could extrapolate from that into the
real world but the real world is
different first of all it's
exponentially bigger and people assume
that go like systematization exists in
the real world right and it's just
trajectories of actions and tasks and
capabilities and the real world isn't
really like that
yeah in a way it is and in a way it
isn't right so yeah that's an additional
trouble these things are are gonna find
themselves
uh be having and yeah so I I'm not I'm
not on board with the with the whole
super intelligence runaway I can
definitely see it in some parts and we
should pay attention and all of that but
in like the the general all-encompassing
sense I I don't think I'm on board
cool okay folks this is just a reminder
that you can get 25 off an annual
subscription and you can start a seven
day trial of blinkist check out the link
in the description cheers